car aujourd'hui d'amour bien mon chéri
alors on va le faire en deux fois je
suis content de ma vision c'est aussi en
deux fois vous faire plaisir c'est alors
jean-luc vous connaisez il a tout ce qui
se passe dans l'émission toutes les
coulisses et parfois il parle même des
invités c'est à dire si on fait
attention on n'avait pas placé charlotte
way était très très étonné qu'ils
avaient déjà provoqué fait bien à
planifier ça c'était jean-michel sa très
belle anecdote merci une question bien
sûr on a les mêmes questions bonjour je
m'appelle lors la semaine dernière vous
avez reçu dans votre émission danièle
gilbert et daniel moreau donc je voulais
savoir comment faites vous pour avoir
toujours les invités qui font l'actu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une boîte à tabac
c'est une très bonne question que vous
posez là lors d'un vrai qu'une seule
réponse le boulot le savoir-faire année
gilbert par exemple c'était des mois de
négociations pour la voir en exclu c'est
normal car daniel est une légende de la
télévision française qui est qu'il ya
d'ailleurs beaucoup impressionné notre
invité du soir benoît dubois
le problème c'est qu'il est aussi
matthieu delormeau qu'il y était un
petit peu moins impressionnée rappelle
pas non il a profité de la situation
pour faire une révélation sur quelqu'un
de l'équipe à
[Musique]
sa grand maman n'était pas du tout
impressionnée mois
il a perdu
la personne
[Musique]
vingt quatre mois
non tu dis toi dan franck
[Musique]
voilà j'ai pas la tête du moteur
à un bisou caresse deux chiens alors là
je peux te dire donne des puces
ben oui on rigole parce que je te
montrer tout jeune et belle oui oui bien
merci d'écouter
merci si je peux te rend service ni
évidemment mathieu montée il avait
beaucoup plus jeune que ça met du coup
benoît a voulu savoir quel âge avait
d'autres membres de la bande
il a encore demandé à l'autre
[Applaudissements]
m
tu m'auras way 350 trop vous avez quel
âge vous 56 56 56 dahouët vous avez aimé
vous êtes plus jeune que j'ai remis ça
se voit c'est évident il est 13 même
temps il a une belle allure des plus
jeunes pardonnez-moi svelte voilà alors
le combo benoît et daniel gilbert joly
suite j'achète un jeu les conversations
était surréaliste on était plus sur un
plateau de télé on était dans un salon
de coiffure au bac à shampoing j'avais
l'impression dans le sketch de muriel
robin vous êtes une petite compil
[Musique]
vous faites les mèches en papier en alu
avec eux
encore s'agit il
moi à les guider les votants
malheureux ton rare oui d'accord et vous
séparer ma l'air libre
la malheureuse
[Musique]
l'homme n'a pas
ça
beaucoup la personnalité la coiffure
salaire beaucoup
c'est sympa pour un coiffeur une épreuve
en voyant ça va
pas vraiment un cadeau
[Musique]
les avait reçus sur michael jackson
vous avez tout intérêt à bobino
alors on passe au top et dans ce cas
c'est ces petits moments embarrassants
de tpm paie donc obligatoirement on
commence par jean-michel voilà qu'il
comprenait pas pourquoi d'un seul coup
il y avait des magnifiques danseuses sur
notre plateau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'ex idole
la poule 1
[Musique]
les téléspectateurs c'est l'indigestion
toi ma belle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
oui
et réussi voici
[Musique]
justifier un appel de quelqu'un de koh
lanta vous justifiez en appel de
quelqu'un de koh lanta mais ces goûters
20 minutes j'avais toujours oui mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il admet qu'il est boudé nous en méfier
de tout le monde elle est place à
l'amour maintenant et la sensualité donc
à cyril hanouna qui a priori a retrouvé
son zizi
il a toujours dit qu'il n'avait pas mais
en fait ils avaient juste égarés alors
bonne nouvelle ou mauvaise nouvelle je
sais pas mais il a retrouvé cette
histoire vous souvenez pas qu'est ce qui
va donc pendant le live de langoustines
galiana il s'est lancé dans une parade
nuptiale qu'on observe d'habitude chez
les araignées sauteuses et d'après vous
qui vous l'été c'est du moins ce dance
c'est quelqu'un qui fait partie de
l'équipe mathieu est une réponse en
images
[Musique]
ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est croyait encore moi je ne sais pas
toi qui m'a [ __ ] maystadt
ça fait longtemps c'est vrai mais bon on
va vous fait désirer je crois qu'on en
parle croyez vendredi à roland garros
aux données cas ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il ya la photo
l'appui de photos dans voici la s en
rendre garros ensemble ou pas à ça non
merci ça
balles neuves
oh oui je te péter la gueule c'est là
bas ça peut être un fantasme
ah voilà merci et voilà comment on
dérape alors j'ai voulu éviter le sujet
suivant mais je suis obligé d'en parler
quand même qu'à quart la semaine
dernière il y avait deux choses
importantes à voir dans le monde
le maillage de mégane et harry et le
shampoing d'isabelle morini-bosc emprise
book live par david a highway alors pour
ceux qui n'auraient pas suivi
l'événement un petit résumé de ce grand
moment qui a fait l'honneur des réseaux
sociaux lorsque je vais vous montrer ses
des sons des images inédites fait à
partir d'un téléphone donc veuillez
pardonner la qualité
l'usi
savoir manger
[Musique]
alors
attends je vais
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comment derrière alors je rassure la spc
la société protectrice des chroniqueurs
personnes étaient maltraités isabelle a
juste été un peu mouillé et déteste ça
parce que ça l'a fait friser parce que
quand vous la voyez dans l'émission
c'est christina cordula lui verser un
verre d'eau sur la tête c'est un jackson
five en tout cas dans sa tête
1 donc comme elle était contrarié
jusqu'à la pause publicitaire suivante
il avait la garde et une serviette sur
la tête et là je voudrais rendre hommage
à l'artiste
parce que franchement je pensais pas
qu'on pouvait être aussi créatif avec
une serviette
[Musique]
tu bosses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je m'en fous
j'ai dit comme ça
[Musique]
au brésil il adore ben laden bon il y en
a un peu plus doux mais quand même notre
jardin secret à les parties et on
commence par benjamin castaldi qui
chaque vendredi de monde au chroniqueur
anonyme qui et leurs animateurs préférés
échec vendredi ils devraient pas
[Musique]
faites moi plaisir quel est votre
animateur préféré c'est nikos ah bon
depuis je fais le vendredi 6 la
production pourrait mettre des gens qui
m'aiment bien
il arrive à trouver et vous savez en
fait j'étais beau petit après j'ai eu un
gros moment j'étais moche et je
redeviens pas mal
après l'été jusqu'à la vente a été très
bon et c'est dommage qu'on change comme
ça alors à gauche il faut que je vous
avoue quelque chose c'est que daniel
moreau est très amoureuse de vous
quelle bataille
[Musique]
moi
on croirait
choix que de revoir tout ça le vrai
amour
[Applaudissements]
le message que ça envoie aux
téléspectateurs parce que réellement des
gens pensent qu'on peut être grassement
payés à ne rien [ __ ]
alors des soirées pâtisserie battu fera
des gants
le plein la nuit chez les toits
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on se marche pas sur la tête
m
le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est amoureux jean mi on a parlé en
loge et mac est l'élément savait qu'on
[Musique]
je suis fan de michael jackson mais
d'exporter mais je ne sais pas là alors
c'est quoi la réponse est oui merci
moi je
m
[Musique]
c'était la règle
non mais plus tard quand j'ai raté
étroite et syrie tu veux te voir les
trois tableaux
[Applaudissements]
ça fait franchement et je t'ai
exceptionnel je les ai qui fait mais
d'où il faut que j'aille les dépanner
aux états unis n'importe quoi gérer
franchement et j'aimerais qu'on
applaudisse traitant jean-luc aubade
[Applaudissements]